لقد كان سباقًا مع الزمن بعد أن
داس دانيلو على لغم أرضي أثناء قيامه بمهمة
خلف
خطوط العدو، فجرني اللغم وحملني
إخوتي لمسافة 7 و 2 كيلومتر
قدموا لي الإسعافات الأولية
وحملوني وأنقذوا حياته لكن إصاباته
كانت  لقد
فقدت إحدى ساقيه بشكل كارثي، لقد
تحطمت والأخرى معلقة
بالكامل
ولكن هذا لا يعيق دانيلو، فهو
يخفي وجهه لأسباب تتعلق بالسلامة
ولكن قصته رائعة
بعد الحادث الذي تعافى منه، حيث سافر
على طول الطريق إلى المكسيك للحصول على  لقد
تعلمت طرفًا صناعيًا المشي مرة أخرى
وقد عادت الآن إلى ساحة
المعركة، لا أستطيع الجلوس في المنزل ومشاهدة
ما يحدث في بلد
يتعرض للهجوم. يجب على كل رجل أن يقف
من على الأريكة ويدافع عن منزله، يجب أن
أفعل ذلك.  وأنا جيد في
ذلك فهو يساهم في
الهجوم المضاد الضخم لأوكرانيا في الجنوب
حيث يقول كيف إن قواتها تحرز
تقدمًا متزايدًا ثيو على الخطوط الأمامية مباشرة
أنا مسؤول عن قاذفة قنابل الهاون
والفرق المضادة للدبابات
قائد الفصيلة  وأنا أختار
المواقع الصحيحة والأهداف وأخطط للعمليات، ولا تزال حقول
الألغام والمدفعية الروسية تسبب الكثير من
الضحايا على
الجانب الأوكراني، وبينما لم تكشف KF عن
الأرقام الدقيقة، فإنها تعترف بأن
القتال صعب، وقد قدم لنا المسعفون هذا الفيديو الذي
يظهر الصدمة التي تعرضوا لها  التعامل مع كل
يوم، أخبرني المسعف فلاد في بعض الأحيان أنهم
ببساطة لا يستطيعون إنقاذ أطراف رفاقهم
أو حتى حياتهم لأن الجروح
شديدة للغاية، كان لدينا حوالي 10 حالات حيث
تم بتر الأطراف بسبب الصدمة
ولم تكن هناك فرصة لإنقاذها مقارنة
بـ  عدد الأشخاص في اللواء
ليس كثيرًا ولكنها
تضحية رهيبة، تضحية غيرت
حياة دانيلو لكنه تكيف وتعلم
التحرك والقتال بفعالية على الرغم من أن
طرفه الاصطناعي يحد من قدرته على
الحركة، ليس لدينا خيار، لا نستطيع
خسارة هذه الحرب، هذا الهجوم المضاد
لا يمكن أن يفشل، ليس لدينا هذا الحق، نحن
ندافع عن وطننا، إنه النصر أو
الموت بالنسبة لنا، لذلك فريد بلين سي إن إن زابارا
أوكرانيا